okay today I'm going to talk to you
about forces and elasticity so when you
apply an force to an object you may
cause it to stretch to compress or to
bend I'm just going to quickly
demonstrate those three onto the spring
so you could stretch it compress it you
push it close together or bend it in
order to do this you need more than one
force acting on the object otherwise
it's simply moving the direction of the
force so for example if there's just one
force it just moves the direction of
force so there needs to be at least two
forces acting in order to do one of
these three things what I'm going to do
is I'm going to draw a quick diagram to
show you some Springs and so we could
learn some key terms that we need to
know so imagine I've got this spring
that's hanging on this stand here now
what I do is let's say I've got this
load which is some hanging masses which
just goes onto the spring now what will
happen is the the force of the of this
mass pulling this down will cause the
spring to extend so we'll have this this
idea of extension now so that's the
first idea this idea of extension so
when we put this mass on it cause it to
extend now an object is except to be
elastically distorted if when we stop
applying the force it will return to the
shape that it did originally so for
example with this spring I stretch it I
want to let it go it returns to this to
the shape so it's original shape so that
is said to be elastic ly distorted
however if I add too much force so let's
add some more of the
hanging masses here so I've got a bigger
load this time I've got a bigger force
and it's kits that we've had much much
greater extension we get to a certain
point which was referred to as the
elastic limit so if we reach our elastic
limit our spring will not be able to
return to its original shape if that's
the case we say about this spring it has
been in elastically in elastically
distorted so it will not return to its
original shape so those are some of the
key turns key terms that we need to know
in order to understand elasticity now
the final thing that we need to know
about really is this concept of work
done so remember whenever we think about
work done we're thinking about how much
energy is being transferred so when a
for stretches or compresses an object it
basically causes energy so energy is
transferred to the elastic potential
energy store potential energy store so
whenever we have any of any of these
kind of weights applied to this spring
we've got this idea of work being done
so energy being transferred please fit
please watch the other videos about
particular experiments to do with
extension and also the equations that
are linked to extension that explain
work done in more detail thank you